the biden administration struggles with
a massive wave of haitian migrants at
the southern border aoc's dressmaker
hasn't paid her fair share and the
pentagon admits it drone to innocence on
the way out of afghanistan i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by express vpn
it's time to stand up to big tech
protect your data at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first a lot of folks starting
to realize you don't need to spend a ton
of money for your cell phone coverage
your cell phone coverage you're spending
a lot of money every month there is no
necessity for that you could be getting
the exact same coverage as one of the
big networks but paying a lot less money
with pure talk usa stop paying for
verizon at t r t mobile's social
initiatives stop paying for their
thousands of retail stores across the
country that you never actually enter
stop paying for their added perks you
never use puretalk doesn't charge you
for any of that garbage instead they
give you the killer 5g coverage on the
same 5g network as one of the big guys
for about half the cost the average
family is saving over 800 a year so
what's your excuse i made the switch you
can keep your number keep your phone or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids you can get unlimited talk
texting six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and if you want unlimited
data they have options there too and
you'll still be saving a bundle head on
over to puretalk.com
shop for the plan that is right for you
they have a 30-day risk-free guarantees
you literally have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com enter promo code shapiro
you will save 50 off your very first
month of coverage that's puretalk.com
promo code shapiro puretalk is simply
smarter wireless alrighty so catastrophe
continues to mount over at the southern
border according to the associated press
haitian migrants seeking to escape
poverty hunger and a feeling of
hopelessness in their home country said
they will not be deterred by u.s plans
to speedily send them back as thousands
of people remain encamped on the texas
border saturday after crossing from
mexico scores of people waded back and
forth across the rio grande on saturday
afternoon re-entering mexico to purchase
water food and diapers in ciudad acuna
before returning to the texas encampment
under a near a bridge in the border city
of del rio now remember we were told a
wall was completely unnecessary because
if there is a river there no one would
actually cross that river well it seems
like people are crossing the river and
then going back and forth across the
river many times and finding as it turns
out holes in america's border system
where they can descend on areas and then
apply for asylum junior jean a 32 year
old man from haiti watched as people
cautiously carried cases of water or
bags of food through the knee-high river
water
jean said he lived on the streets in
chile the past four years resigned to
searching for food in garbage cans
okay so what drove him now if he was in
chile for the past four years what
exactly was the big driver right now
could have something to do with the
advent of a brand new administration
that is not led by donald trump he said
we're all looking for a better life the
department of homeland security said
saturday had moved about 2 000 of the
migrants from the camp to other
locations on friday for processing and
possible removal from the united states
they also said they'd have 400 agents
and officers in the area by monday
morning now here's the reason why they
are doing that the reason that they are
sending a bunch of new officers is of
course because it had been humiliating
to them that the state of texas had
actually intervened and sent its own
officers
right that's actually what happened here
is that the state of texas
sent law enforcement officers according
to daily wire law enforcement officials
with the state of texas appear to have
taken control of the situation in del
rio texas after the biden administration
repeatedly failed to stop tens of
thousands of migrants from illegally
entering the united states governor greg
abbott said in its week the texas
department of public safety is in full
force along the border around the del
rio area and then he put out a picture
that showed scores of law enforcement
vehicles that had descended on the area
he said they built a barricade with
their squad cars and state troopers the
national guard is working with them to
secure the border as well
fox news national correspondent bill
mclugan tweeted out a video showing the
massive surge in law enforcement
presence at the border
the texas department of public safety
tweeted out photographs from both the
ground and from their drone showing the
scale of the abbot response to the
crisis that started late last week and
erupted over the past few days and of
course the texas department of public
safety noted their response came after
the federal government had failed to
secure the board when we say they had
failed to secure the border we actually
have some pictures and video of what it
looks like when you fail to secure the
border here is a picture from the air of
the migrant camp which is under a
freeway overpass and if you can't see it
i will describe it for you it is
literally thousands upon thousands of
people who are standing under an
overpass many of them in 100 degree heat
a lot of them as it turns out from some
of the from some of the video have built
themselves sort of ram shackle
structures using essentially leaves and
sticks in order that they don't burn to
death or dehydrate to death under the
overpass so it's a humanitarian crisis
as well fox news is bill mclugan he says
listen our border is wide open
this is where hundreds of people are
streaming into the united states
illegally right now uh certainly does
not look like an international border
there but you can see the crowds of
people down there these are people who
have just crossed it and brian if we can
pan up that dirt path take a look that's
where they're all walking to the bridge
right now that's why there's so many
people under the bridge you can see them
streaming in across the rio grande
that's when they officially cross
illegally into the united states and
seeing the scope of it all over the
place
it's wild i mean our border is wide open
where you're looking at right now yeah
amazingly the faa had actually attempted
to ban drone footage from this
particular area citing lack of safety
protocols which of course is incredibly
silly because they've had drones over
there for quite a while that was purely
an attempt to stop the news from
covering it and then when they got
caught then they reversed themselves
some of the video from under the bridge
is just as disturbing as some of the
you know 500 000 foot video that you're
seeing right there here's some of the
video from from underneath the bridge
that was taken also by bill mclugan
if you can't see it again you're seeing
huge crowds of people these are the
structures i was talking about blankets
small children some of the people who
are who are sitting here in the in the
sunshine
it's unbelievable there's a refugee camp
directly on the board now i have a
question where is aoc she still at the
met gala i was told that that i know
that that parking lots adjacent to
holding facilities really upset her
upset her so much that she shows up
there wearing white costumes and uh and
then stands outside and cries directly
into camera i know it's very upsetting
to see large stretches of pavement and
no actual migrants there but you know
when there's like thousands of migrants
under an overpass many of them suffering
from humanitarian need i don't see her
anywhere but i guess she was at the met
gala so she was she was you know she was
busy and meanwhile the democratic mayor
of del rio is slamming joe biden
he is his name is bruno ralphie lazana
he tweeted out the us is failing to
protect its borders why aren't you here
he was tweeting out at vice president
kamala harris
okay
meanwhile you had the uh representative
august flager republican of texas saying
yeah this is a pretty major crisis that
we are looking at right now this is not
just some sort of temporary problem and
of course this is part of a broader
crisis okay here's representative flager
you can see the tragedy coming across
the weir dam we're about 100 yards away
from the international bridge in del rio
over 14 800 people as of this morning up
from 12 000 up from 10 000 and this week
we have surged from one to two thousand
to fourteen thousand this is a crisis we
need the administration to call it a
crisis to take action not just here but
all along our southern border where
we're gonna have two million people
illegal immigrants that are documented
that doesn't include the guidance that
doesn't include the known or suspected
terrorist we need the administration to
do something right now according to
fluger a lot of these people are
military-aged males he reportedly told
fox news there was allegedly criminal
activity taking place in the area where
illegal immigrants were staying under
the bridge
according to fluger the border officials
told him this was the worst that they
have ever seen it he also said this was
worse than you could imagine and he said
the worst is yet to come because if they
decide to riot or if unrest happened it
would be a terrible situation it's ripe
it's 100 degrees outside right now you
literally have 14 878 people here that's
how serious the situation is right now
even the new york times reported that
local officials are describing the scene
as a quote shanty town with little
access to clean water and food and just
a few portable toilets the times noted
no running water at the site photos
showed people having to carry large
packages of bottled water into the area
so as i say the governor of texas sent
some people in there to try and clean
things up and this then prompted the
biden administration to respond we'll
get to that in just one moment first let
us talk about the decoration of your
home so you've remade a lot of your
house already right i mean you made it
look better you repainted it recently
got some new furniture but something
still looks a little bit dingy now look
around what is it it is your window
coverings you've not updated those since
president eisenhower was in office you
need to update your blinds blinds.com
makes it simple to shop top quality
custom blind shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping the experts
at blinds.com understand that window
treatments are one of those household
items you don't think about but they can
make a huge impact on the look and feel
of your home you don't need to do a full
renovation by simply changing what's on
your windows you can change the way
light comes into your home and create a
totally different feel go to blinds.com
just take a look at all the options
they've got faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades even outdoor shades
all customizable to your specific
dimensions and if you're nervous about
trying them their sure-fit guarantee has
you covered blinds.com has helped
millions of homeowners through the
process plus they guarantee the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or have
them measure and install everything for
you right now go check it out see how
much you can save at blinds.com when you
check out online don't forget to tell
them you heard about blinds.com from the
ben shapiro show rules and restrictions
may apply okay so the u.s is now saying
that we are going to start flying people
out of there apparently we're going to
start flying five to eight flights a day
from the area starting on sunday another
official from the government expected no
more than two a day said everyone would
be tested for coven 19. now remember
that had been one of the republican
complaints that people who are being
released into the interior of the united
states are not actually being tested for
covet 19 before they are being released
told of the us's plans on saturday
several migrants said they still
intended to remain in the encampment and
seeking asylum some spoke of the most
recent devastating earthquake in haiti
as well as the assassination of
president jovenal moisey saying they
were afraid to return to a country that
seemed more unstable than when they left
in the first place
it was a full-scale disaster area again
the reason this is happening is not just
because of foreign crisis
the reality is foreign crisis exists all
over the world
for
oodles of time the northern triangle
countries have had serious internal
problems for decades at this point there
is nothing new under the sun what
changed here is that joe biden became
president and people have decided that
they are now going to try to brave the
journey hoping that joe biden is going
to let them in this is finally prompting
dhs to use some trumpian type language
the department of homeland security said
quote our borders are not open people
should not make the dangerous journey
individuals and families are subject to
border restrictions including expulsions
of the agency irregular migration poses
a significant threat to the health and
welfare of border communities and to the
lives of migrants themselves and should
not be attempted but of course there
have been a lot of public interviews
with people who are attempting to make
that crossing and it turns out that many
of them are saying we don't believe you
we think that you are faking and we
think that in reality if we cross the
border and if we are released into the
interior you will plan immediately to
give us some sort of amnesty which of
course is true
which is why you've seen a massive surge
since joe biden was elected in the first
place according to the washington post
this is as of last month the number of
migrants detained along the mexico
border crossed a new threshold in july
exceeding 200 000 people for the first
time in 21 years according to cbp
among the 213 000 migrants taken into us
custody in july of this year or 83 000
family members and 19 000 unaccompanied
teenagers and children that was an
all-time high as well again aoc nowhere
to be found she was wearing a tax the
rich stress created as it turns out by a
possible tax cheat so you know she's
busy she's busy
as of july more than 15 000 miners who
arrived without parents were in
government custody many sleeping in grim
military barracks a south texas park
along the rio grande had been converted
into a sprawling quarantine camp for
more than a thousand parents and
children who had tested positive for
covet or been exposed to infection
all of this by the way has prompted the
biden administration
to actually embrace many of the exact
same policies that the trump
administration embraced so now they've
surged a bunch of people to the border
according to the wall street journal the
biden administration sent more agents to
the texas bridge to move haitian
migrants this was as of sunday the biden
administration said it would be sending
additional border agents u.s customs and
border protection plans to send 400
agents and officers to del rio and was
moving migrants to other processing
locations along the border including
about 2000 on friday now remember that
still leaves somewhere between 12 and 13
000 people who are not moved from that
area as of sunday dhs also said they
were going to start flying people back
to haiti on sunday as well
haitians apparently have been coming at
a steady clip all year long to del rio a
remote border region of the border west
of san antonio creating a fresh
humanitarian crisis in a year when
illegal boarding when illegal border
crossings have hit a two-decade high
and the biden administration has been
struggling to handle a crush of asylum
seekers the border patrol has facilities
that are not large enough to accommodate
the recent crush they've instead been
holding migrants under the bridge often
for days because they literally have no
place else to put these people and they
are processing their immigration
paperwork
so
full-on disaster on thursday by the way
a federal judge in washington ruled the
biden administration was violating
immigration law by rapidly expelling
migrant families using the title 42
policy that judge stated the effect of
his decision for two weeks
on friday the administration appealed
the decision to a higher court so the
obama administration came into office
pledging they were going to reverse all
of trump's evil horrible no good very
bad immigration policies and they've
been avidly attempting to
reinforce those exact same policies
while claiming that they have radically
changed things
right so you get the worst of both
worlds you get the administration which
is apparently engaging in precisely the
sort of evil humanitarian
anti-humanitarian measures as trump and
the messages come on in
which is rather conflict which is rather
conflicting
box.com reported on this just a little
while ago
they reported quote despite promises to
institute a more humane immigration
policy the biden administration has
clung to pandemic-related border
restrictions like title 42 implemented
by the trump administration last year
since march 2020 that policy had been
had been used to rapidly expel more than
a million migrants without hearings
before an immigration judge
biden also pledged to remember that he
was going to get rid of trump's remain
in mexico policy this is people who were
applying for asylum and the idea was
that instead of us releasing you to the
interior while you await your court
hearing instead if you want to apply for
asylum you gotta wait in mexico while we
go through your paperwork
okay trump had negotiated that deal with
the mexican government and now biden
came in he said i'm getting rid of it
but he reversed himself because it turns
out that when you reverse all of the
sensical logical policies bad things
happen
all the while biden's message has been
quote unquote don't come
toward haitians specifically biden's
policies are wildly inconsistent again
this isn't me this is vox.com which is a
biden shearing section quote he has
allowed more than a hundred thousand
haitians already living in the u.s to
apply for temporary protected status at
the same time he has continued to
prevent haitians waiting on the other
side of the us-mexico border from
entering under title 42 and to the shock
of immigration advocates resumed
deportation flights to haiti on
wednesday
so
again conflicting policy
bad policy
bad
rhetoric
and the predictable result is a mess on
the board remember kamala harris was
supposed to solve this didn't they put
her in charge of the border crisis
that was funny i mean not like not like
funny enough for kamala harris to laugh
the way she does that's just weird but
but funny that they put her in charge of
the border crisis and it's been a
complete and utter failure
this is just part and parcel again of
the internally conflicting messaging of
this administration and the wild
incompetence of this administration as
well
it's amazing that the rip on trump is
that his team was wildly incompetent
i'll tell you a few things that trump
didn't do
he didn't lead to a 21-year high in
illegal immigration
and have no actual plan to deal with it
he also i noticed didn't abandon
afghanistan to the tender predations of
the taliban and leave thousands of green
card holders behind notice that one as
well
as we'll get to in a little while he
also didn't have relations so bad with
the french that they actually withdrew
their own ambassador that's something
that happened over the last three days
i'll get some more on this in just one
second first let us talk about a simple
fact you need your sleep i need my sleep
let me tell you you can see i'm away
from home right now i'll tell you what i
miss right to this very instant i wish
our opponent right now my helix sleep
mattress helix has a quiz it takes just
two minutes to complete it matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique helix knows
that they have several different
mattress models to choose from they've
got soft medium and firm mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot mattress is great for
spinal alignment to prevent the morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you're
matched to the mattress comes directly
to your door shipped for free you don't
ever need to go to a mattress store
again they've got the 10-year warranty
you have to try out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix has financing options flexible
payment plans a great night's sleep is
never far away head on over to
helixsleep.com right now take that two
minute sleep quiz they will match you to
a customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com go check
them out helixsleep.com
ben alrighty so the media is beginning
to notice that this is a complete mess
chuck todd of msnbc over the weekend he
said i've noticed that there's a bit of
a credibility crisis here for the
president of the united states
i think he's got a a pretty big
credibility crisis on his hands because
all of these problems in some ways
showed up after he said
something basically the exact opposite
afghanistan withdrawal wasn't going to
be messy this wasn't going to look like
saigon it's got a lot of work to do the
un speech look he's got some credibility
issues on the world stage uh are uh to
see make sure that people still view uh
america as a
not just a stable democracy but a
competent
leader of the free world right now
pretty amazing words from chuck todd
again that is over on nbc's meet the
press that's a pretty far cry from
return of competence return of normalcy
the adults are back in charge the adults
are not back in charge by the way one of
the reasons why so many people were
attempting to
cross the border illegally is they were
figuring that joe biden would find some
sort of way not to prosecute them and to
allow them into the country broad scale
well one of those provisions just went
down in flaming defeat on sunday evening
because the senate parliamentarian ruled
correctly that democrats cannot include
a pathway to citizenship in their 3.5
trillion social spending bill so
remember the rules of the senate are
that you can not pass any sort of bill
unless you have 60 votes right you have
to have a filibuster proof majority
order pass a bill unless you're talking
about a budget bill but there are some
rules
the bird rules under reconciliation in
which 50 plus one is enough to get you
over the finish line so this creates a
bizarre incentive structure where
democrats try to shove everything
humanly possible into their budget bills
and then claim that this is all budget
stuff so if they can shove immigration
into the budget bill it only takes 50
votes plus one in the form of the vice
president of the united states but there
is a senate parliamentarian who can look
at this and say hold up a second this is
an immigration bill this has nothing to
do with the budget what are you talking
about you can't just take random crap
and throw it in a budget bill then be
like hey this thing that i just came up
with five seconds ago is actually about
the budget so the senate parliamentarian
said you can't do that on immigration so
joe biden will of course claim to his
people that he attempted to get it done
and then just failed and it really isn't
his fault but the bottom line is this it
is another failure for joe biden he
doesn't get his immigration bill through
senate majority senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell
he said senate rules never contemplated
a majority circumventing the filibuster
by pretending that sweeping in
transformational new policies were mere
budgetary changes tonight's ruling
confirms that principle democrats will
not be able to stuff their most radical
amnesty proposals into a reckless taxing
and spending spree they are assembling
behind closed doors this just
illustrates how radical democrats
aspirations are and how unmoored their
far left wish list has become from the
procedures they want to use to ram it
through
that of course is exactly right and that
3.5 trillion dollar package by the way
is still in some pretty significant
danger
joe manchin the senator from west
virginia who's of course a democrat he
told a group of employees at procter and
gamble in martinsburg
that he wanted to pause all talk about
any 3.5 trillion dollar bill until 2022
that is unlikely to to pass if this
delays all the way until next year it's
going nowhere because in an election
year you think any purple district
democrat is going to vote in favor of
this giant boondoggle
axio says any delay on the democrat only
reconciliation package could also
imperil the house passage of the
separate 1.2 trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill because democrats
are caught between a rock and a hard
place they've got the moderates like
mansion and cinema who don't want to
vote for the 3.5 trillion bill and then
they have the bernie sanders crew who
won't vote for the 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill that's bipartisan
unless they get the 3.5 trillion dollar
bill
so they've created a box of their own
making and there's no way for them to
get out
the immigration issue being stripped
from the budget by the way the senate
parliamentarian wrote finally it's
important to note that an obvious
corollary of a finding that this
proposal is appropriate for inclusion
and reconciliation would would be that
it could be repealed by a simple
majority vote in a subsequent
reconciliation measure
perhaps more critically permitting this
provision in reconciliation would set a
precedent that could be used to argue
that rescinding any immigration status
from anyone would be permissible because
the policy of stripping status from any
immigrant does not vastly outweigh
whatever budgetary impact there might be
that would be a stunning development but
a logical outgrowth of permitting this
proposed change in reconciliation and as
further evidence the policy changes of
this proposal far outweigh the budgetary
impact scored to it and is not
appropriate for inclusion and
reconciliation right so bottom line is
that it's not mainly a budget issue and
so it is stripped out and then there are
a bunch of legal reasons why that is the
case but that is a giant fail for joe
biden and the fails don't stop there the
failures just continue because this is a
failed presidency and we are not even a
year in we'll get to more in one second
first
let us talk about a simple fact if
you've got a medical problem you really
should just go get it solved now you sit
around you wait on a medical problem
typically it gets worse at the very
least it stays just as bad how often do
you leave a a real serious nagging
medical problem it just kind of goes
away on its own not often instead go
check out roman with roman you get a
free online evaluation and ongoing care
for erectile dysfunction all from the
comfort and privacy of your home roman
ready means confidence the confidence
you know you can rise to the occasion in
the moment a u.s licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships you free with two
day shipping the whole process is
straightforward convenient and discreet
getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com complete an online visit
take care of your edu without leaving
your home complete that online visit
today connect with a us licensed
healthcare professional and get it taken
care of today go to getroman.com
ben right now you get 15 bucks off your
very first month of coverage that's
g-e-t
r-o-m-a-n dot com slash been right now
at 15 bucks off your very first month it
really is time to get that medical issue
taken care of don't sit around and wait
on your ed instead get it solved
remember get started today you save 15
bucks on your very first order of edu
treatment
let's get roman.com
ben for 15 bucks off your very first
month okay that is not the only
major budgetary fail for joe biden so
right now he's running up against
another catch-22 for himself
so right now they're coming up on the
debt ceiling negotiation so in 2019
congress suspended the debt ceiling for
two years
but the policy's expiration occurred at
the beginning of august
so treasury secretary janet yellen
stepped in and she used extraordinary
cash saving measures to fund the federal
government so he didn't run up against
the debt ceiling now what the debt
ceiling really is about is about being
able to borrow more money in order to
pay off our current debt servicing okay
so it is not just about you just raise
the debt ceiling willy-nilly it's really
supposed to be that you're allowed to
raise the debt ceiling a little bit at a
time so you can ensure that when we sell
more bonds for example that we are using
that money in order to pay off the bonds
that we actually have to pay off right
now
right if we've got servicing on our
national debt we still have to pay that
off that's typically what the debt
ceiling is for however the debt ceiling
has become an issue of negotiation
specifically because we have taken out
so much debt to pay for our
extraordinary national debt our
extraordinary national debt we have well
over 20 trillion dollars at this point
in national debt the total national debt
of the united states
currently stands at
something like
29 trillion dollars 29
trillion dollars it's a number that
boggles the mind if you look at the
national debt over the course of the
last several decades
the worst points in american history
were nowhere close to this
right if you just look at where we were
even
a few years back like in 2000
the us national debt as a percentage of
gdp was like
in 2000 maybe 35 40 of our national debt
we're already looking at nearly 100 of
our national debt and joe biden is
blowing out the spending even more okay
like the the the total amount of
u.s public debt right now is just insane
and continues to to be completely insane
so
raising the debt ceiling so that we can
spend 3.5 trillion more dollars is
obviously something that republicans are
not going to go for the problem of
course is that if we don't raise the
debt ceiling they won't be able to pass
this bill
and so republicans are saying we're not
going to raise the debt ceiling well if
the debt ceiling doesn't get raised we
also can't service our debt if we can't
service our debt then our debt gets
downgraded on the world markets if our
debt gets downgraded on the world
markets theoretically we can't fund any
of our outstanding obligations if we
can't fund any of our outstanding
obligations we are no longer in spend
money mode we are now in austerity mode
or raise taxes fairly dramatically
fairly quickly mode and a recession is
likely to follow
so democrats are trying to basically
blackmail republicans with the debt
ceiling into you have to raise the debt
ceiling so we can get our 3.5 trillion
dollar behemoth across the finish line
republicans are like nope we're not
going to do it
on september 17th cnn obtained a letter
sent by the biden administration to
state governments warning that failure
to raise the debt limit would throw the
economy into recession here's what the
biden administration said quote raising
or suspending the debt limit does not
authorize new spending commitments it
simply enables the government to pay for
obligations congresses and presidents of
both parties have already approved we
expect congress to act promptly to raise
or suspend the debt limit and protect
the full faith and credit of the united
states hitting the debt ceiling could
cause a recession economic growth would
falter unemployment rise the labor
market would lose millions of jobs city
and state revenues often decline during
a recession as revenues fall due to
declining incomes and spending if the
u.s defaults on its debt cities and
states could experience a double whammy
following revenues and no federal aid
because congress could not actually pay
for all that federal aid
the letter lists a bunch of state
programs that would be affected by a
default on the federal debt meanwhile
republicans in congress are saying
listen
you want to spend this much money on the
debt do it
senate minority leader mcconnell says
quote i can't imagine a single
republican in this environment that
we're in now is free for all for taxes
and spending voting to raise the debt
limit
the answer is they need to put the debt
limit in the reconciliation bill
the current national debt is 28.7
trillion dollars so again biden is
really stuck here and the more radical
the policies he pushes the more likely
he is to fail
okay even with members of his own party
over the weekend arizona democrat
kristen cinema delivered yet another
devastating blow to democrat president
biden's 3.5 trillion bill according to
daily wire reportedly informing the
white house she will not support their
drug pricing reforms so joe biden
basically wants to use our
governmentally funded health care system
in order to cram down drug prices on the
drug manufacturers the only problem is
the vast majority of drugs are actually
developed and created in the united
states if you cram down below market
prices on drugs using things like
medicare
all you're going to end up doing is
destroying half the r d industry so you
know big pharma the worst people in the
world who just ended the pandemic
because they created these magnificent
new drugs remember those people so joe
biden would like to basically use our
government in order to cram down pricing
on that now the reason he's doing that
is because other governments abroad do
that right canada does that the eu will
do that you'll see other governments
that will collectively bargain against
the drug companies and then artificially
lower the price and so what tends to
happen is that we the american people
tend to absorb the price of the higher
cost of the drugs
one of the ways to push back against
that would be to say to foreign
governments as part of our foreign
policy you cannot do that you have to
pay market price for drugs developed in
the united states
cinema met with joe biden on september
15th according to politico to discuss
the social spending package cinema has
made her resistance to the current house
prescription drug negotiation proposal
cleared to the white house it's unclear
if she's completely immovable
that is the latest blow to biden's plan
and of course
we've already heard about joe manchin
objecting to the bottom line of the bill
he also objects to a lot of the
environmental provisions of the bill
which totally undercut coal which of
course in west virginia is a major
industry all of this is a disaster for
the biden administration so what is
biden falling back on he's falling back
on just plain old class warfare
and you know things are tired when
you're just going right back to the
class warfare gambit so here's joe biden
over the weekend doing his yeah i love
capitalism
but we're going to pay your fair share
big corporations and super wealthy have
to start paying their fair share of
taxes
it's long overdue
i'm not out to punish anyone i'm a
capitalist
if you can make a million or a billion
dollars that's great god bless you
all i'm asking is you pay
your fair share
uh no that's not what you're asking so
you'll notice that the words fair share
tend to mean whatever rate i save for
you today
what exactly if you ever ask a democrat
what a fair share constitutes they'll
never give you a straight answer because
if they said you should pay your share
of for example the national income
people at the top of the income bracket
already pay more than their fair share
of the national income
the top one percent pays 40 of all
income taxes in america
the top 10 percent pay all of the net
income taxes in the united states like
beyond
receiving any benefits because if you're
very rich you don't receive any benefits
from the federal government basically
this notion that the rich don't pay
their fair share in the united states is
absurd the united states actually has
one of the most progressive tax systems
in the world in the world why
because all other countries have super
high tax rates for people who are in the
middle income brackets or the lower
income brackets even if you're living in
scandinavia you're getting taxed at like
60 if you're making 60 70 000 bucks a
year
all those social programs have a cost
so when joe biden says i'm a capitalist
but pay your fair share he doesn't mean
that he means i don't really like
capitalism all that much we understand
that it sort of pays the bills and what
i'd really like to do is just suck money
out of the people who actually are
earning a lot of money
to pay for my programs but not even to
pay for my programs because i'm not
going to pay for my programs i have no
plans to pay for my programs
all the class warfare stuff by the way
is just a shtick it's a it's a play for
the suckers okay all all the folks who
are at the bottom of the income spectrum
who look at joe biden and they look at
the aoc's the world and the bernie
sanders they say oh those are people who
are standing up for the little people
like me honestly at least bernie sanders
is honest he wants to screw the little
people directly he's like okay if you're
in the middle you should pay a 60 tax
rate okay more credit to him seriously
more credit to him
but if you're joe biden or aos you just
lie to people you're like oh well i'm
out there to soak the rich no you're not
you're out there to hang out with the
rich and take donations from the rich
and and hobnob with the rich and have
them pay for all of your campaign
that's what you're there for
and then you're there to yell at the
rich every so often so that you can
sucker the rubes into supporting you
it's all a game
and by the way if you didn't know it's
all a game let me just recommend that
you watch a little video of aoc okay so
there's a video of aoc going around
before she went to the met gala wearing
a
a very expensive dress that said tax the
rich on the back of it
okay this video is kind of astonishing
because all it is is her being treated
like princess dye
you got a makeup artist she's got a
whole team she's got people she's got
people who are wearing tuxes around her
she's kind of dismissive of the little
people and then she walks in and all the
people are cheering for her and they all
understand that they're part of the gag
they don't feel like they're targeted by
her tax the rich dress they know that
they agree with her
they don't agree with her enough to
actually you know
not avoid the taxes but but they agree
with her on principle which is that they
are the special people they are among
the specials
and here's a little bit of that video
it's gonna be punk rock it's very punk
rock peak punk rock
[Music]
wasn't that jazzy and fun
guys wasn't that great
she was super sincere about it though
she's really sincere she really wants to
attach to tax all the rich people by the
way she really you know she wants to tax
the most she really wants to tax rich
people like say like aurora james
and this lady is a really famous dress
designer apparently aurora james and she
needs to be taxed more because
apparently she's not only very wealthy
and runs a pretty large company but also
this person happens to be a notorious
deadbeat on taxes with unpaid debts
dogging her in multiple states
apparently right isn't that like a
perfect candidate for aoc to target in
her tax the rich dress oh sorry no sorry
aurora james made that dress
for aoc
and is the person who's been cheating on
her taxes apparently apparently she has
significant amounts in back taxes
most of her debts center around a
company she created in 2011 cultural
brokerage agency it serves as the parent
company to repair it to her current
fashion company the new york post
reports quote the company racked up
three open tax warrants in new york
for failing to withhold income taxes
from employees paychecks totaling 15
grand the state department of taxation
and finance told the post the debt
stemmed from 2018 and 2019. the company
has been hit with 15 warrants in total
since 2015.
the company gotten into an even deeper
hole with the feds between april 2018
and april 2019 the irs placed six
federal liens on cultural brokerage
agency totaling over a hundred thousand
dollars the lien specifically cited the
company's failure to remit employee
payroll taxes
apparently that didn't stop james from
receiving forty one thousand dollars in
pandemic relief aid
her company owes sixty three thousand
dollars in matters related to workers
comp her company has allegedly relied
heavily on legions of unpaid interns
working full-time jobs wait i was told
unpaid internships were evil by aoc
that's that's crazy also james just
bought a 1.6 million dollar property in
california last year it's already listed
as delinquent by l.a county because she
apparently owes more than 2 500 bucks in
a property tax
well
so um
yeah so that so tax the rich except for
the lady who made this dress for the met
gala who hasn't paid her taxes but did
take federal money and who was
photographed with nancy remember how aoc
characterized her as a woman of color
living a victimized life in america
yeah man
it's all a game it's all a game to these
folks
by the way in case you don't believe
it's all the games of these folks
i'm just going to remind you that if
you're not special the rule if you're
not special then the rules apply to you
and if you are special the rules don't
apply to you
right if you are a masculist san
francisco mayor you can party it up if
you're london breed the mayor of san
francis like how many
i i would say she should apologize but
there's no point you might end up
governor of california
and apparently immune to recall here's
london breed at a concert
am i partying it up good times in san
francisco
nobody here is wearing a mask
no i've been told everyone needs to wear
a mask right even the vaccinated but is
anyone there wearing a mask nope not a
single one not a single one the rules
don't apply to these people by the way
the emmys which happened last night i
noticed that no one was wearing a mask
no one not a single human was wearing a
mask
amazing
apparently uh seth rogen who is the
presenter who's just an awful garbage of
a human he appeared baffled by the
indoor setting
because apparently he was supposed to
take place in an air conditioned tent
but this was fully enclosed
he said i would not have come to this
why is there a roof but he did he stayed
and uh they all stayed there
unmasked but then again they're not you
know small children if you're a small
chill if you're a small child then you
must mask
if you're this video is going around
over the weekend of a small toddler
being forced to mask by a preschool
teacher
[Music]
who's in new york state
still whines less than most democrats
but is subject to the rules because he's
a child
it's unbelievable unbelievable
it's just honestly it's just garbage and
it's unbelievable if you're london breed
the mayor of san francisco you can go to
a big party with a bunch of other adults
who are much more likely to infect each
other with serious illness
and uh if you're a child then we'll
force you to mask because you're not one
of the special people that is the way
that all of this works
and they don't hold to any real standard
about any of this okay in just one
second we'll get to the latest in
afghanistan where it turns out that uh
yeah we basically just nuked a family
for no reason other than joe biden
needed a headline as we left we'll get
to that in a second first let us talk
about a simple fact you need to refi
your home if you haven't right now the
rates are super duper low you're missing
out go refi your home right now if you
own a home and you haven't what are you
waiting for mortgage rates are lower
than ever all you have to do is call
american financing america's home for
home loans take advantage of a free
mortgage review that is correct free
meaning no pressure no obligation no
upfront or hidden fees just a simple
conversation with a salary-based
mortgage consultant someone who's going
to listen to and guide you so you're
getting a custom loan that achieves your
goals from lower rates to shorter terms
even debt consolidation they've got you
covered so do not put off a refi any
longer there are still options in the
twos but they cannot stay this low
forever pre-qualify for free by calling
866-721-3300 that is
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
again that is americanfinancing.net or
prequalify for free by calling 866 721
3300 that is 866 721
3300. already in just one second we'll
continue with the news out of
afghanistan by the way we still how many
people with green cards are still stuck
there i know we forgot about them that
was the plan after all we'll get to that
in a moment first the biden
administration has declared war on all
businesses with over 100 employees in
the form of mandatory vaccinations or
mandatory weekly testing and that the
daily wire is fighting this tooth and
nail we will find ourselves in court
undoubtedly i myself am vaccinated i'm a
big advocate of vaccinating but i also
believe that human beings in the united
states are free and that means that once
i'm vaccinated and i'm good to go i
really do not have the right to tell
anybody else what they ought to do with
regard to vaccination i can encourage
but i certainly shouldn't be using my
power as an employer to threaten them
with firing at the behest of slo joe
biden head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe right now and help us out
because it's going to cost us some money
i mean we're going to go to court we're
going to try and push this thing all the
way to the supreme court if need be use
code do not comply at checkout for 25
percent off americans have been really
willing over the last year and a half to
cede their freedoms to authoritarian
bureaucrats in the name of public health
enough is enough so please stand with us
at the daily wire most importantly stand
with the rights of all americans you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
meanwhile the biden administration's
foreign policy continues its own
disastrous unfolding remember that time
when we left afghanistan and we left
like 100 american citizens behind and
then probably thousands of green card
holders and probably tens of thousands
of siv holders remember that time and
that was bad right you don't remember it
because the media just moved right past
it the the biden administration kept
saying this is part of the plan all this
is planned it's all
the only thing that was planned is that
you would forget about it the only thing
that was planned is the news cycle would
move on and then you just wouldn't care
anymore and so they continue to count on
the fact that you don't care on the way
out
remember we were leaving
isis k decided they would bomb the the
exit point and they killed 13 american
service people and joe biden immediately
struck back like a man ward and he
struck back by droning a key member of
isis case somebody who's planning a
follow-on attack
and there was only one awkward problem
which is that reports came out almost
immediately that the person who had been
droned was not in fact a terrorist that
person was in fact somebody who'd worked
with the americans and also we killed
his kids
and the biden administration immediately
went out there with no no no we would
never do that are you crazy this just
demonstrates this is a successful strike
it demonstrates our over the horizon
capacity you remember this was the
phrase they always use over the horizon
over the horizon right
from anywhere over the horizon we can
strike with pinpoint accuracy targets
well it turns out that when you rely on
the taliban to do your spotting for you
you might just kill innocent people and
that's exactly what happened admiral
brett mckenzie or kenneth mckenzie
rather the u.s marine corps general
kenneth mckenzie
who's the commander of centcom uh he
admitted over the weekend oh yeah by the
way remember that time we told you we
had this super successful strike where
we killed a terrorist and and stopped a
terror attack yeah we killed just some
rando in his family
i am now convinced that as many as 10
civilians including up to seven children
were tragically killed in that strike
moreover we now assess that it is
unlikely that the vehicle and those who
died were associated with isis k or were
a direct threat to u.s forces
i offer my profound condolences to the
family and friends of those who were
killed
this strike was taken in the earnest
belief that it would prevent an imminent
threat to our forces and the evacuees at
the airport but it was a mistake
and i offer my sincere apology well i'm
sure that apology will uh will be worth
nothing
like literally nothing less than nothing
now i have a question how do we get the
intel on that
who's providing the intel on that right
we had no troops on the ground in that
area so where was the intel coming from
who was telling us that this was a
terrorist
presumably the same people who are
telling us what isis k was doing namely
the taliban the us is apparently
considering reparation payments to
surviving family members but mackenzie
said making such payments could prove
difficult because uh we can't even do
that we don't even have people on the
ground to pay the person's family
he literally said yeah we would send
them a check but the problem is we then
have to send a check to the taliban and
they'll just take the check
now recall that it was the pentagon
saying that we had killed two isis k
fighters believed to be involved in
planning attacks against u.s forces in
kabul
at the time army major general william
taylor said there were no known civilian
casualties and pentagon spokesman john
kirby said the u.s did not notify or
coordinate with the taliban ahead of the
strike he said the defense department
did not notify other countries in the
region or u.s lawmakers okay so here are
the possibilities either we got the
intel from the taliban or we didn't and
we were using those magical over the
horizon capabilities where we don't have
anyone on the ground to verify a damn
thing and all we have is drone footage
and so we can't tell whether this is a
guy pouring water bottles to put in his
trunk to take home or whether it is a
guy pouring gasoline to put in his trunk
to bomb some sort of outpost
you know what had been helpful having
some actual intel capacity on the ground
but we don't have that anymore
so well done biden administration really
well done
okay by the way that is not the only
massive foreign policy debacle of the
weekend
so the united states has been attempting
to face up to the threat of china in the
south china sea that's a good thing one
of the ways they're doing this is
they've been developing the biden
administration has their relationship
with the australians there's only one
problem normally the australians tend to
get their military tech from france and
the united states works with france in
order to provide that military tech
right we have american military
contractors who work with french
companies working with the french
military to provide that tech
well now the biden administration with
no notice whatsoever to the french just
decided to basically undercut their
military their department of defense
essentially and this has now caused the
greatest
foreign policy rift between france and
the united states in decades
according to the new york times
calling american and australian behavior
unacceptable between allies and partners
france announced on friday it was
recalling its ambassadors to both
countries in protest over president
biden's decision to provide
nuclear-powered submarines to australia
that's not because they don't want
australia to be armed because france was
the one doing the arming
australia cancelled a 66 billion
agreement to purchase french-built
conventionally powered subs hours before
the deal with washington and london was
announced
the statement said at the request of the
president of the republic i've decided
to immediately recall our two
ambassadors to the u.s and australia to
paris for consultation this exceptional
decision is made by the
is justified by the exceptional gravity
of the announcements made on september
15th by australia and the united states
so even the new york times has to say
even though the relations between europe
and trump were strained they never
reached this point
so congratulations to joe biden he has
defeated donald trump once again
he has failed where trump did not
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show that's available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
the fda rejects covet booster shots for
most americans the feds hold a fake
january 6th reunion and the faa prevents
news drones from broadcasting the flood
of foreigners crossing our southern
border check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]
you